[Música]
o la de emergencia ante el posible
fracaso de las negociaciones postres y
la unión europea activa las medidas para
mitigar los efectos que la salida
británica pueda provocar a partir del
primero de enero el bloque y reino
unido- continuarán negociando un posible
pacto hasta el domingo imputado el
primer ministro en funciones del líbano
por las explosiones en el puerto de
beirut que dejaron más de 200 muertos en
el juez imputó por negligencia y por
causar las muertes al hasan diab que
dimitió del cargo el 10 de octubre y a
tres antiguos ministros de su gobierno
la próxima semana se realizarán los
interrogatorios ya dijo que manejó con
transparencia lo ocurrido hoy se celebra
el día internacional de los derechos
humanos
naciones unidas- hizo un llamado para
que tras la pandemia los líderes se
centren en proteger a las personas con
discriminación en pleno 2020 el
colectivo lgbt continúa siendo uno de
los más excluidos y perseguidos del
mundo
hola como estan saludamos con gusto a
todos ustedes que nos siguen por la
señal de france 24 mi nombre es alan
austria y hoy que es 10 de diciembre
sean bienvenidos la unión europea
presentó un plan de emergencia ante la
posibilidad de que no se logre un
acuerdo post break sheet con reino unido
la iniciativa se centra en cuatro puntos
las conexiones aéreas fundamentales con
reino unido la seguridad aérea los
transportes terrestres y un marco legal
sobre pesca úrsula von der leyen también
indicó que el bloque y los británicos
continuarán negociando hasta el domingo
la presidenta de la comisión europea y
el primer ministro británico señalaron
que las diferencias siguen siendo muy
grandes en los asuntos clave tras
reunirse anoche en bruselas
we will grant estamos dispuestos a
conceder el acceso al mercado único a
nuestros amigos británicos es el mercado
único más grande del mundo pero las
condiciones tienen que ser justas tienen
que ser justas para nuestros
trabajadores y para nuestras empresas y
este fino equilibrio de justicia no se
ha logrado hasta ahora nuestros
negociadores siguen trabajando y
tomaremos una decisión el domingo
este plan fue anunciado por la
presidenta de la comisión europea al
inicio de la reunión del consejo europeo
donde los líderes se encuentran reunidos
en bruselas y discuten iniciativas para
desbloquear el plan de recuperación post
pandemia y el presupuesto del bloque
2021 2027 que asciende a 218 millones de
dólares ambos planes han sido vetados
por hungría y polonia la unión europea
condicionó la liberación de fondos al
respecto a los estándares del estado de
derecho el gobierno húngaro y el polaco
ambos nacionalistas se oponen a esa
cláusula
el bloque acusa a varsovia y a budapest
de imponer controles políticos sobre el
poder judicial
y los medios de comunicación y otras
instituciones polonia y hungría aseguran
que la unión europea sólo busca una
intromisión en sus asuntos internos
escuchemos lo que dijeron el primer
ministro polaco y la canciller alemana
al respecto
y esperamos que en las conclusiones del
consejo europeo haya cláusulas que
diferencian entre la protección del
presupuesto el control del presupuesto
la prevención del fraude la corrupción y
el llamado estado de derechos
en los últimos días alemania y yo
personalmente así como mi personal hemos
trabajado muy intensamente en la
superación de las dificultades que hemos
tenido y en encontrar una solución para
dar cabida a las preocupaciones de
hungría y polonia manteniendo al mismo
tiempo la condicionalidad y el estado de
derecho tal como lo negociamos con el
parlamento europeo y seguimos en francia
donde nicolas sarkozy ex presidente se
enfrenta a un juicio que termina en las
próximas horas esto en el tribunal de
parís por los supuestos delitos de
corrupción y tráfico de influencias
luego de que prometiera un ascenso a un
magistrado del tribunal supremo a cambio
de información confidencial sobre otra
investigación en la que estaba implicado
la defensa e insiste en que las
acusaciones carecen de contenido y pidió
que sea absuelto de los cargos que
enfrenta el martes se había presentado
la fiscalía para pedir una pena de dos
años de prisión contra el ex mandatario
francés y el resto de los imputados más
otros dos años exentos de cumplimiento-
el líbano el primer ministro en
funciones hasan diab y otros tres ex
ministros fueron imputados por el juez
que investiga la explosión del 4 de
agosto en el puerto de beirut por
negligencia y por causar la muerte de
más de 200 personas
el responsable del caso indicó que el
lunes martes y miércoles de la próxima
semana se realizarán los interrogatorios
nuestra corresponsal en beirut hotel
bonet nos detalló la respuesta por parte
de hasan diab quien dimitió a raíz de
las protestas desencadenadas tras la
tragedia el primer ministro en funciones
hasan diab ha dicho que no colaborará
más con la justicia después de que esta
mañana el juez fadis aguán que lleva las
investigaciones por la explosión del
puerto de beirut le haya acusado de
negligencia a él ya tres ministros de su
gabinete porque conocían la existencia
de las 2.750 toneladas de nitrato de
amonio almacenadas en el puerto de
beirut y que a pesar de haber recibido
varias advertencias de la peligrosidad
que suponía tener este tipo de
fertilizante altamente explosivo
almacenado en una
en el centro de la ciudad no tomaron
ninguna medida de seguridad día para
dicho que él tiene las manos limpias y
la conciencia tranquila y que ya habló
en su momento cuando fue interrogado
después de la explosión del 4 de agosto
que mató a 200 personas y dio a otras 6
mil y otras 300.000 personas se quedaron
sin hogar
díaz ha acusado al propio juez de haber
violado la constitución ya que tiene
inmunidad política y que debería haber
primero pasado por el parlamento la
acusación antes de haberla hecho no está
claro ni no se sabe los pasos que tomará
el premier libanés pero lo que sí está
claro que no querer colaborar con la
justicia devolverá de nuevo la ira de
los libaneses el presidente turco recip
tayip erdogán aseguró durante una visita
a bakú que la lucha de su aliado
azerbayán contra armenia no había
terminado después de los enfrentamientos
en nagorno karabaj a su viaje se produce
un mes después de la derrota militar
armenio
y acusa la turquía de implicarse
directamente en los combates y que tuvo
que ceder importantes territorios en
nagorno karabaj y alrededor del enclave
en virtud de un acuerdo que puso fin a
las hostilidades en bakú se celebra este
día el triunfo obtenido en estos
enfrentamientos
wallis se ven hay que ver que no se
puede llegar a ninguna parte con los
imperialistas occidentales dándote
confianza los lazos deben ser
reevaluados con base en la vecindad en
lugar de la enemistad si el pueblo de
armenia aprender las lecciones de lo que
ocurrió en caravaca será el comienzo de
una nueva era en la región
en bardas se encuentra nuestro enviado
especial adrià rocha te saludamos en
bakú donde se celebra este día el
triunfo obtenido en estos
enfrentamientos adrià como se realizaban
los eventos militares en la plaza de la
libertad
pues si alan la gran presencia del
presidente turco recep erdogán ha sido
lo más destacado
perdimos la comunicación con nuestro
enviado especial adrià roig e
intentaremos retomar los les pedimos una
disculpa por nosotros temas y es que el
presidente saliente de eeuu donald trump
anunció que ha firmado una proclamación
reconociendo la soberanía marroquí sobre
el sahara occidental
trump escribió en twitter que la
propuesta de autonomía sería creíble y
realista de marruecos es la única base
para una solución justa y duradera para
la paz y la prosperidad duraderas
trump también anunció que israel y
marruecos han normalizado los lazos y
acordaron relaciones diplomáticas plenas
además el asesor principal de la casa
blanca- jared kushner aseguró que cree
inevitable que arabia saudita reconozca
a israel por los con temas de la
pandemia y es que los casos del
coronavirus en todo el mundo superan los
69 millones y las muertes se elevan a un
millón 573.000 veamos más noticias que
deja el coronavirus en esta jornada
los contagios en alemania muestran una
tendencia preocupante las autoridades
contabilizaron un nuevo máximo de 23 mil
679 nuevos casos en las últimas 24 horas
mientras que las cifras de víctimas
mortales fue de 440 fallecidos
eeuu registró la cifra más alta de
fallecimientos a consecuencia del hobby
19 desde el inicio de la pandemia en el
país al contabilizarse un récord de 3
mil 124 muertes la cantidad de
fallecidos durante las últimas 24 horas
supera a las víctimas de los atentados
terroristas del 11 de septiembre
la organización panamericana de la salud
advirtió de que en las últimas semanas
la región de las américas registra los
niveles más altos de nuevos casos desde
el inicio de la pandemia especialmente
en canadá y estados unidos así como en
centroamérica y brasil-chile ha sufrido
un fuerte repunte en su número de
muertes diarias registrando 84 en las
últimas 24 horas
nos vamos a áfrica el presidente de
ghana nana akufo addo ganó las
elecciones del pasado lunes al obtener
el 51 59 por ciento de los votos con lo
que logra un segundo mandato de cuatro
años
el mandatario de 76 años venció a otros
11 candidatos entre ellos su principal
adversario el ex presidente john dramani
mahama del partido congreso nacional
democrático el principal de la oposición
que rechazó la victoria y calificó estos
comicios de defectuosos desde accra
nuestra enviada especial
marian con él nos dio más detalles al
respecto
es oficial el presidente actual está
comenzando un segundo y último mandato
presidencial según las cifras temporales
de la comisión electoral el engaño estas
elecciones presidenciales con un poco
más de 52 por ciento de los votos esta
victoria no es una sorpresa en realidad
porque las encuestas lo mostraron como
el gran ganador de estas elecciones
tampoco es sin sorpresa que el partido
de la oposición que quedó en segundo
lugar con más de 47 por ciento de los
votos refutar a los resultados y pide un
recuento de los votos en algunas
regiones como recordar yo este lunes
poco más de 17 millones de ghaneses
fueron invitados a votar por su futuro
presidente de la república y sus
senadores aunque todos alguien bien la
policía indicó que las violencias
causaron la muerte de cinco personas y
que 17 resultaron heridas
las violencias estalló el lunes día de
la votación y el martes mientras el
recuerdo de los votos
en diferente parte del país hoy se
conmemora el día internacional de los
derechos humanos el secretario general
de la onu antonio guterres pidió a los
líderes mundiales que tras superar la
pandemia los esfuerzos se centren en el
respeto y reconocimiento de los derechos
de todas las personas uno de los
colectivos más discriminados y
perseguidos en el mundo es el lg y es
que en pleno 2020 la homosexualidad es
penada hasta en 69 países de los cuales
en 12 se condena a muerte ayer michelle
bachelet la alta comisionada de las
naciones unidas para los derechos
humanos dio un discurso emotivo en el
que se refirió a las múltiples crisis
humanitarias que ha enfrentado el mundo
de este año entre otros temas también
señaló los objetivos que deberían seguir
los líderes para pensar en el mundo
después del joven diciembre 19 ha
concentrado las fisuras y fragilidades
de nuestras sociedades exponiendo todos
nuestros fracasos en inversión en la
construcción de sociedades justas y
equitativas ha mostrado la debilidad de
los sistemas que no han logrado dar un
enfoque central a la defensa de los
derechos humanos
holding human rigths la cámara de
diputados de argentina inició la
discusión del proyecto de ley de
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo es
la segunda vez que el congreso debatirá
la normativa que fracasó en 2018 por
decisión del senado pero es la primera
vez que esta iniciativa es propuesta
directamente por el presidente alberto
fernández el proyecto permite que el
acceso al aborto se produzca hasta la
semana 14 de gestación y más allá en
casos de violación o si la vida de la
madre corre de peligro la discusión se
produce cuando el mandatario cumple un
año en el cargo
en otros temas el director ejecutivo del
programa mundial de alimentos de la onu
david beasley recibió el nobel de paz en
un acto virtual celebrado en oslo y roma
el funcionario alertó sobre el peligro
de una pandemia de hambre al tiempo que
denunció que 270 millones de personas
más que toda la población de europa
occidental están a las puertas de la
hambruna beesley y resaltó que la
alimentación es el camino hacia la paz
este premio nobel de la paz es más que
un agradecimiento es un llamado a la
acción debido a tantas guerras al cambio
climático uso generalizado del hambre
como arma política y militar y a una
pandemia de salud mundial que empeora
todo esto de manera exponencial 270
millones de personas están marchando
hacia la inanición si no se atienden sus
necesidades se producirá una pandemia de
hambre que empeorará el impacto del cobi
y por si fuera poco de esos 270 millones
30 millones dependen de nosotros al cien
por ciento para su supervivencia
y finalizamos en eeuu un cohete starship
de la compañía spacex explotó el
miércoles durante un aterrizaje de
prueba en el estado de texas la nave
había despegado de la base y logró
ascender a unos 12 kilómetros antes de
volver al punto donde debía posarse el
presidente de spacex elon musk explicó
que el accidente se debió a que la
presión del tanque de combustible del
cohete era baja lo que causó que hubiera
una alta velocidad al momento de
aterrizar
pues llegamos al final de esta emisión
les agradecemos mucho su compañía les
recordamos que la información no se
detiene con actualizaciones constantes
aquí en nuestra señal televisiva pero
también noticias al momento en nuestro
sitio web france24 puntocom
muchas gracias nuevamente por su
compañía cuídense cuídense mucho del
hobbit 19
[Música]